Where is the European Union? Undoubtedly somewhere, but just like in the continent
the European itself, which has an ambiguous boundary, the European Union also has ambiguous edges
for her.
To begin with, the official members of the European Union are in the descending order of the population:
* Germany * France
* United Kingdom * Italy
* Spain * Poland
* Romania * Kingdom of the Netherlands
* Greece * Belgium
* Portugal * Czech Republic
* Hungary * Sweden
* Austria * Bulgaria
* Denmark * Slovakia
* Finland * Ireland
* Croatia * Lithuania
* Latvia * Slovenia
* Estonia * Cyprus
* Luxembourg * Malta
The edges of the EU will probably continue to expand further than there are other states
at different stages trying to become a member.
Just as the works of the European Union are very complicated,
but for this video you only need to know three things:
1. States pay membership and
2. Vote for the laws they all have to follow and
3. Citizens of member states are automatically citizens of the European Union as well
The latter means that if you are a citizen of any of these places you are free to live
and work retired into any state by others .. What's good especially if you think of your place
is too big or too small or very hot or too cold. The European Union gives you the options.
By the way, did you notice how all three of these statements have attached the stars
this unhelpful explanation? Well, get used to this: Europe loves the stars to add exceptions
for complex deals.
These three, for example, lead us to the first part of border crossing with Norway,
Iceland, and Liechtenstein. None of which are in the European Union, but if you are
an EU citizen that you can live in these states and the Norwegians, Icelanders, or Liechtensteiners
can live on yours.
Why? In exchange for the freedom of movement of people that they have to pay membership fees
in the European Union - although they are not a part of it and so will not take a role
in her laws they have to follow.
This agreement is the European Economic Area and it looks like a terrible deal, yes
the imo was for that star which gives the EEE but no EU members a transition to some areas
law, especially agriculture and fishing - something a state like Iceland can take care of
much to do their way.
Between the European Union and the European Economic Area, the continent appears to be largely covered,
with the exception of Switzerland, which remains neutral and fiercely independent,
except for its participation in the Schengen Area.
If you are from a country that keeps its borders very clean and / or well-patrolled,
The Schengen area is a bit unbelievable because it is an agreement between states to take
a 'meh' border approach.
At the international borders the Schengen area looks like this: no border officers or passport controls
of any kind. You can walk from Lisbon to Tallinn without identification or without
answering the question: "business or pleasure?".
Because Switzerland was part of the Schengen, but it is not part of the European Union means that
non-Swiss people can enter at any time they want, but they can never stay.
This border approach has not been appreciated by all in the EU: mostly, the Kingdom
the United Kingdom and Ireland who argue that the islands are different. So go on these islands
honest, you will need a passport and a good reason.
The reluctance of the UK to get fully involved with the EU brings us to another theme: money.
The European Union has its own sophisticated currency, the Euro used by most, but not all
members of the European Union. This economic union is called the Eurozone and unite
in one country must first achieve certain financial goals - and lying about achieving these goals
certainly is not something that someone will do.
Most non-eurozone members, when they meet their goals, will leave their local currency
in favor of the Euro, but three of them Denmark, Sweden and, of course, the United Kingdom,
have drawn stars into the Euro section of the treaty giving them a permanent exclusion.
And strange, four small European countries Andorra, San Marino, Monaco and the Vatican
have a star giving them the opposite: the right to print and use the Euro as much as their money,
even though they are not in the European Union.
So this is the whole prospect: there is the EU, which makes all the rules, the eurozone inside
that with a common currency, of the European Economic Zone outside of it, where people can move freely
and selective Schengen, for countries that think borders are worthless.
As you can see, there are some strange overlaps with these boundaries, but we're not ending talking
about complications for a long time, because the emperor.
So Portugal and Spain have their islands from a colonial day that they have never shared with:
these are Madeira and the Canary Islands are on the shores of Africa and the Azores as well
in the Atlantic. Because these islands are Spanish and Portuguese they are part of
The European Union too.
Adding a few islands to the EU borders is not a big thing until you consider France:
the queen of the non-let go. It still holds on a bunch of islands in the Caribbean, Reunion
off the coast of Madagascar and French Guiana in South America. As far as France is concerned,
these are too France, which in itself expands the edge-to-edge distance of the Union
Europe across a third of the Earth's Earth.
Collectively, these pieces of France, Spain and Portugal are called the Foreign Regions
and they are the result of the simple answer of the empire: just keep it.
On the other hand, it is the United Kingdom, the master of maintaining complex relationships
with its quasi-ex-lands - and it's not alone in this on such a continent
empire-happy.
The Netherlands and Denmark and France (again) all have what the European Union calls Territories
Outside: they are not part of the European Union, instead they are an endless hole
the stars because of their complicated relations with both the European Union
and their related places which makes it difficult to say a meaningful thing about them as a group
but...
in general the law of the European Union does not apply in these countries, although in general people
who live there are citizens of the European Union because in general they have citizenship
of their respective country, so in general they can live anywhere in the EU they want
but in general other citizens of the European Union can not move freely in these territories.
Which makes these sites weird the right European Union membrane and
the last part we are going to talk about in detail though there are still many,
many more one-miles stars you can stumble upon, such as: The Isle of Man, or those Spanish Cities
in North Africa or Gibraltar, who claims to be part of Southwest England sometimes,
or that region in Greece, where it is entirely legal to forbid women, or Sebei and friends
who are part of the Netherlands and so should be part of the EU, but not the Isles
Faroe Islands upon which while the citizens of Denmark live they lose their citizenship in the EU, and over
and over it goes on.
These stars almost never end, but this video needs.